[Music]
huh I want that all in there every time
I want you just like smacking your hands
and setting up all on camera every time
Bobbie Lee is coming shortly so for
those people who have YouTube me and
messaged me the interview is here we
just do an intro that's right Bobby you
get fast forward if you want to hope you
don't cuz intros are sometimes fun you
get a little information but Bobby Lee
is coming up hilarious intense
everything you've ever dreamed of holy
crap I don't think he gets more serious
Bobby Lee than on my podcast he opened
ventually get serious you have to write
well he will get there you're gonna
laugh you're gonna go oh my god and then
you're gonna go WOW and then he lets go
and he doesn't I think he does with me
because we both experience a lot of
stuff in our lives and we've been
friends for a long time and it's nice
that he's comfortable enough to he just
supports me he has such successful
podcasts he has to now and they're both
incredibly successful and yet I know it
doesn't have any time but he's come on
the podcast again he actually came with
kalila to the other pockets I had and
I've been on his show four times and
we're just buddies guys whatever you
need and that's what I like is I have
friends that are incredibly busy and
they're just busy and they're not coming
back on the podcast they don't have time
for it they're doing and I'm grateful if
they even came on so that's all you
asked for but Bobby Lee is the kind of
friend Nick Swardson Tom Welling these
guys come back Stephen Amell
jamie-lynn Sigler they come back on the
podcast and that's really uh it's really
cool man it's cool when they take time
from their busy lives to join us and
share personal [ __ ] man uh you know I
don't want to get into all the
coronavirus stuff you know you guys hear
about that on the news everything you
don't wanna hear it you know it's been a
lot of stuff and there's so much
misinformation and all this and you know
you don't know what to believe and now I
believe in quarantine yourself if you
think you're at risk and you think
you're it and the big problem is is you
know I'm not again I'm not a doctor Ryan
but don't you think the big problem is
spreading it to people who have weak
immune systems and all these
pre-existing conditions or old people so
I get it I'm not going around them and
I'm gonna try and limit the amount of
people I even see which is hard because
I need to be around people yeah I mean I
think the thing is just
once your wash your hand irresponsible
be responsible don't be a [ __ ] don't go
out to the bars stay out of groups yep
we're trying to minimize I think if you
just minimize everything right now and
this we don't have the medical supplies
to do account for that it's crazy it's
just it's just a crazy world of never I
mean you know I think it were really
when it got got when they said the NBA
shutting down you know you're at South
by Southwest she said okay mmm-hmm NBA
NHL when the then the stock markets but
you're like wow this is canceled there's
something serious yeah but you know you
stick together we've you know this the
planet has made it through so many
things that doesn't mean you should take
it lightly just means young do the best
you can and try to be responsible and
smart that's all I'm not gonna I'm gonna
end that I don't think we need to talk
about that anymore you know before we
get to my good friend Bobby Lee I just
want to say again thank you for
listening to the podcast I say it
because I just do without your
subscription without your listening and
you know the little notification thing
on the YouTube Ryan works so hard so I
commend you on that and I really hope
you guys give the video a chance watch
it listen you know you could listen to
it subscribe but watch it too and spread
the word share it
the interviews are great with jamie-lynn
Sigler I teared up I did tear down my
face it was it was intense was beautiful
funny it was everything the Martin Starr
was a great interview was a great
interview and he got deep and I just
give it a chance you know
also shout out to the patrons I did a
live pas I've been doing since I'm you
know at home mostly now I've been doing
live instagrams I've been doing live
Facebook's
and all of a sudden people are joining
patreon they're subscribing because the
subscription to to the podcast is free
but people are you know donating a
dollar five dollars a hundred dollars a
month to you know to help the podcast
and but by the way you don't just do
that and get nothing for it there's
bonus footage which we're going to shoot
one today there's inside of me that the
the patrons get to ask I respond a lot
on there it's like a community
friends and I always said if he gets to
a certain point where it's big enough
for you know it's paying for everything
and we're doing well
hey let's let's have a patreon party a
patreon party in LA I'll rent a place
out or my backyard but we just beat
patrons maybe few celebs but no randos
no randos are showing up it's like
everybody knows are you a patron yeah
cool great that's it and you Ryan and me
I'm invited yeah Bryce has invited
Jess's invited you guys all work great
so join patreon whatever is great I
appreciate that the podcast the live
podcast was cancelled for March 31st and
that was at the north door and we have
changed it to July 2nd
so go on my Instagram or my Twitter it's
at the north door in Austin and it's
gonna sell out so we're doing two shows
at 7:30 to 9:30 at the north door on
July 2nd and that's gonna it's a
Thursday night so it's a better night
for people it's gonna be great hopefully
you know it gets best things get better
and by July we're good to go
uh Camp Rosie people have been talking
about it my first camp adult camp I'm
doing for the October Halloween weekend
30th and 31st you're gonna go to that
right no because the wedding I was
supposed to go to in April isn't a move
to that we've changed why would anybody
have a [ __ ] wedding on that weekend
cuz it's England and they don't really
do Halloween stuff Halloween originated
in Ireland that's not England but it's
close it sounds good job point being I
can't go to the camp Rosie because my
cousin's wedding is now that weekend
right okay but the the camp rosie is
gonna be on that weekend let me tell you
there'll be links soon so just wait for
it but it will sell out probably 150 to
200 people that's all that can attend
there's gonna be some some tickets that
you can get that maybe room near my bunk
or in my area in my cabin nut bunk you
don't just put theirs bunks and cabins
sure includes your food your your snacks
all your alcohol your bedding your
activities parties costume Kyle it's
gonna be a freakin blast and we'll get
more into that so also if you want to
get any merch from left on Laurel my
band or the podcast inside of you go to
inside of you online
we've got great podcasts coming up
great guests and you know at a time like
this when we're sitting around we you
know you need to I hope people will
continue to be pockets at least we had
things in the can we got things in the
can for for the next at least a month at
least a month and great guest so yeah
let's talk to Bobby Lee right now he's
hilarious I've known it for a long time
he he'll surprise you he'll upset you
both both at the same time it's it's
he's something else
and he goes balls out literally but
check this out check this podcasts out
let's get inside of Bobby Lee it's my
point of view you're listening to inside
of you with Michael Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
what is this I like this guy but you
said next enter the yeah this is Ryan
he's the engineer I love him rides the
best you've never met him yes I have a
beer
I've never know let me just now oh
because I like it the profile your face
you look like a hawk
a [ __ ] hawk a hawk yeah he's got one of
those angular hawk faces oh you be it
president like Delia president Krista
Lyon on the coin you would your profile
with president talk he does have a good
like a Lincoln face yeah Lincoln I don't
know are you producing the show now or
what uh yeah numbered sitting here
recording things in the [ __ ] are you
this your show right now I could just
watch you interview him all day now did
you know we're starting I was just
asking some questions I need I need to
know about my environment you thought I
was gonna be angry I the first thing I
said to Ryan was like Bobby's gonna come
in pissed off if he's the one who's two
hours that's right you know the guy
you've known forever
ya know because um yeah I want to I want
to be on time for you and you know I
said yesterday I go
what about 4:30 and then you said he
felt like you were like it's gotta be
four and then all of a sudden I'm like
what's in my head not just listen so in
my head I'm like how am I gonna examine
Culver City was it was a bald-headed guy
that does America's Got Talent
Mickey Rourke Mickey Rourke no no who
was it uh Howie Mandel yeah was with
that guy and that Filipino guy jo koy
yeah and then I was there with them at
the Amazons and I was like looking at
the clock I'm a psychic now three four
he went to Amazon the studio Amazon not
the Amazons no we went the Amazons in
the South Africa America South America
South America's were the Amazon I was
flying there from there no we were at
the company and we're pitching something
and then I was like oh in my head and I
said
out loud I go Lex Luthor is gonna be mad
if I don't leave now
and they're like who's Lex Luthor I go
Michael Rosenbaum they go fans all that
stuff you did not yeah you did yeah
because I was panicking why were you
panicking you're the one who's like I
got to do the [ __ ] Rosa Maz podcast I
would do anything for you but my point
is is that you were the one that was
like it's gotta be for anyway we're here
and we're doing it I didn't say it had
to be for I just said hey you know how
you let's that's it did you
Jesus Christ dude I love I'm blown away
by we haven't talked since you went to
off to that well in the center there's
your coffee oh my god timing thank you
so much
look at that thanks Jess Thank You Jess
I just remember you always like you know
you're sleeping on a couch you're doing
all these things you was always a funny
lovable guy we all loved you we all
rooting for you at least I was and now I
think you're like you're like taking
you're making so much money you are like
you [ __ ] you you are oh no oh you're
[ __ ] don't try to act humble don't you
[ __ ] your you know I'm so happy that up
like that
you are so listening nothing going
you're a regular dude who's now [ __ ]
doing it everybody wants you you're with
Howie Howie Mandel this is dude you're
doing Tupac all right hang on a second
if you want to do this that's you used
to live in an apartment I did four
podcasts that most any guest is come on
I want to hear of a little apartment our
favorite person I love you and in fact
oh you're getting all your fans every
time it's funny because I would read the
comments they go well if Rosenbaum would
do [ __ ] video we'd we'd watch his
[ __ ] show tell it and I was like we
got to do video that's the reason I did
video is because your fans said that
they'd watch if I in their clever I
listened to them yeah yeah they're
intrinsically
clever they are you listen to them too I
listen to everything what they say
everything yeah the way I dress the way
I behave the way I walk does it bother
you when they socially don't they're not
there because I don't listen what's the
worst thing someone said about you
that's a fan that loves you but said
[ __ ] yeah see somebody said shut up you
[ __ ] wasn't a white person though I did
you know how sometimes the profile photo
is like you know we have like
a piece of like a flower sometimes they
do that right so you don't know who the
face yeah or sometimes it's like you
know me the symbol of some sort of
sporting esteem right but the Kansas
City people whatever the Catena achieves
all right
you know and they won right they did I
said think no they didn't yes I saw the
game you were there no what happened was
I um I was in Hawaii and I was flying to
Hawaii and in line was this Chinese
fella he was in the Hawaii five-o you
were in Hawaii five-o to now magnum p.i
magnum p.i he he was also in the Lost
was a chest just look at Chinese fellas
named Daniel Daniel Daniel did Kim's the
great great actor so he's in line with
him in this Chinese fellow and he goes
up he's Korean I was wrong Rachel that's
what I was I was like I didn't know the
[ __ ] said um you know he had some
Corona Corona by a mask on he didn't you
know he goes hey I go what's that Ryan
and he goes he goes come to my house to
watch
he lives in Hawaii to watch the Super
Bowl now I've never seen a Super Bowl my
whole life but when he asked me I was
like I have to do it I went to lock him
is that why you began and I went to his
house and I watched this whole football
game the first one I've ever seen with
his kids and his family was she Pleasant
it seemed very normal to me you know so
that's how I know about the Kansas City
normal like at people's houses that
aren't like you like when you're hanging
around normal people who don't want you
to start like [ __ ] on the floor or
doing about licking someone's dick on
camera like those are things that are
blasphemous things you're saying I don't
do either one of us saw a video that
Santino the great Santino the great
Santino I kissed his orange sack okay an
in Korean culture
if you that's a lie you know you're
about to tell a lie let's sure yeah I
guess Korean culture like I know I kiss
the sack you kissed the side yeah
because it's a yes I think it was a sack
I think it was a shaft I looked at it
and I think I'm gonna kissed it so I
would know my assistant Jess goes
you have to see this I saw it she goes
it's so fine she started show me I don't
want to see it why I don't know why it
wasn't like I thought it was it was fine
but it was just like what what yeah it
was almost like was it too much did you
think you crossed the line I swear to
God I would kiss the tip of your bear
dick you would for you if you pulled it
down go kiss the tip of my bear dick on
my Jewish penis whatever it is you don't
can you not racist I don't think about
it okay yeah I don't want to know what
it is right this guy no he's heard of
going cut yeah this guy no I would not
do him but you'd really if I stood up
right now on camera and said kiss the
tip of my penis you would do it yeah
because I say yeah it's on camera it's a
yes and thing you know deny when you're
doing improv you don't deny right so if
he pulls his penis out on camera it's
show biz friend right so you have to yes
and it you can't deny it and go I don't
want to do it that's against the improv
rules all right right so it's like
that's the deal so I heard that you
apologized for it you felt bad about it
I didn't feel bad about it but I feel
bad because you know that you know I
have some reputation things out there
that aren't true and but it's like it oh
it by pissing on ornament orange man's
penis orange man you mean by redhead red
orange man's penis on camera it would it
validates those rumors that aren't true
about me right if he would do this why
he would do this he would do that yeah
right right yeah yeah yeah you've done
some provocative things in your life
like what well I remember this story
where you took a euphoric not you ought
to defecated on a Comedy Central other
that's a true it's MADtv and gets a
defecated but that right there I don't
feel bad for because that was called um
its shadow play with shadow play it's a
Joy Division song I like true a
diversion I don't know what this but I
just use it that world shadow play you
just like it's like I would take play in
the shadows right shadows and number two
it was it was he deserved it the pool
wasn't for just just shots for Jacques
Vallee
he was revenge alright do you think you
have to up the ante I'm being honest
with you do you think you only get Ryan
don't
select do you think Bobby Lee now cuz
you're Bobby Lee you are you're a
fixture is that the right word you know
in America people's homes people know
you people you're nothing you don't have
you are an internet show idea what the
[ __ ] I've been going through lately what
well we could last two days I've been
like hey y'all let me finish as you
certainly make faces when I cut you off
you look at me like oh you're feisty
today I love that go ahead [ __ ] your
show go ahead no I'm just saying do you
feel like you have to up the ante all
the time because I kissed this shaft or
his sack now I have to go to the next
thing because they're expecting more do
you feel there's a pressure well first
of all I think that every man has kissed
a shaft one time in their life not by
choice sometimes maybe not my choice but
they have do you think every man has at
least kissed a shaft yeah Ryan may I ask
you have you ever kissed a shaft
uh no I'd not okay okay so you were
wrong does kalila ever go Bobby Bobby
would you kissed your friends you're in
business with here's a threat first of
all it wasn't his bearish [ __ ] he was
through his underwear second of all he
said the whole bit was smell my dick did
you actually smell it yeah so he pulled
it out to smell it his real dick no the
what you saw on the internet right right
so he pulled it out he'd go smell it and
I was supposed to smell it but a switch
went off and I went I just kissed him
you kissed it and it was a European kiss
it wasn't like you know it was like an
Italian kiss me know is you sure that's
French I don't know yeah whatever yeah
European yeah if you a rattlesnake bit
your dick you and you know that hold the
whole story yeah I know make that thing
like if you when they get drunk suck it
out you suck it out for a million dollar
I would suck venom out of your dick if
you were gonna die this did you notice
that what you're you're answering a
question and then this is what's called
a non sequitur he completely went to a
rattlesnake biting my dick
by the way inside he fans if you're
listening we will get together to a
darker place but right now we have to
let some of this sort of just land what
I love about this is it you know
you have Tiger belly right now now you
have a new show what's a call path runs
bad friends away the top stay Andrew
Santino's in the top sex line I know it
is I've never been in the top 16
alright I'm relying on your fans for
being true and loyal no but so I love
Santino he's very funny you guys I have
a great chemistry you and I could have
done one you didn't ask me you could ask
me what are you doing it's too late now
alright but why a year ago kissing a
Jewish guys what years ago didn't you
ask me I you're doing the show I didn't
think you wanted another podcast yeah
I'm just saying you my brother - my
brother Steve you know I would have done
with him as well if he would ask me
Andrews the one that went we're doing it
this date I'm gonna buy the equipment
you know I get to be I have to be
coerced into doing it but let me ask you
something this is a serious question I
want you to be honest with me go ahead
do you think it's too much now you're
gonna quit tiger belly no no do you
think you're gonna keep Tiger belly 100%
Lilly's my number one so you're gonna
keep both of them yeah you realize this
was that's a lot of work well you know
Theo Vaughn has three he does he does
yeah he has one with job he has one on
his own he has one that he does with the
guests that's three a lot of people you
know Rogan does four or five a week
sometimes two a day would you do this
only if somebody said you can never act
again no stand-up you just do your
podcast be gonna make millions of
dollars what you are no I can't do that
you'd have to say no because my dream is
bigger than that my dream is uh and I
you know you've so funny because I ran
into Joe Rogan last night and we were
talking about how you don't need to [ __ ]
with Hollywood anymore because we are
taking control of our own destinies
we don't have to wait in line you know
you know what it's like you wait in line
you sign up you you wait for the call
try to get an audition right cause you
know that they tell you what to do
you're in control with the podcast
you're in control of yours as well
correct I am but I don't have the luxury
of you know you fortunately for you look
I love mine I'm gonna keep my doing mine
and mine's doing good but you know it's
like how long you been doing yours for
two years okay we've been doing ours
what for for yeah for the first two
years we didn't make any money
yeah that's it's it's a slow thing
doing it I'm very good at it you're very
good at it and you know when I when you
did ours before you even had this one I
thought to myself this is something
that's down
Mikey's [ __ ] Lane man well thanks and
you oh yeah it's so supportive and I
will always do yours and you'll always
do our Z your family your family so my
point is is that I don't know why I had
to come in here and you be so hostile
toward me and so aggressive you mean you
got eagle face over here writing down
all bunch of notes right you got [ __ ]
you know you're accusing me of sucking
dicks on the sly you know I mean I don't
get it
I came here and I'm always gonna do this
show and I keep him for you you fought
do you know what I asked kalila
sometimes cuz she but she keeps your
life together she does and I say hey
could we go get dinner somewhere so she
has to go to I do you have time these
days to actually let me just finish what
I was gonna say earlier ok ok so what's
so funny that you say the things are
good and you know me and this and that
because they're not ok I'll tell you why
ok ok I sit around every I wake up every
day and I still have the same fears and
the same like why didn't this happen
yeah I mean I wish this would have
happened I don't have this it's human
condition and human nature right you're
never gonna be happy because it because
success and money and all this stuff it
doesn't fix you as you well know
it just it doesn't doesn't no one can
understand that though if they're broke
or they're not making money they think
you guys are [ __ ] idiots you have the
rest you have your look what you're
doing right we need to look at that I
know that the way you get through it is
you go I wanted do you do sometimes you
do a gratitude list no on right I do a
gratitude list I look around my
environment I try to be mindful about my
surroundings you and I I went to a
Wellness Center and then you went to one
about a year later and I'm seeing the
things that I learned through you now
keep going I like it you know what I
don't like what you're doing you try to
skew the [ __ ] thing to I know where
you were heading and I'm trying to lay
out the opposite or whether no but I
it's because I want it I want the push
and pull I love the push and pull I like
it to heaven yeah you know we'll talk
about the dicks later and the sucking
but the thing is is that
Eagle face Eagle Eagle what's up man you
good no no go back no don't tell me what
to do I already got this this was you
were getting this is the oh you I wanna
I want the audience to see the real Bob
because you know no one asked you to get
deep on these other guys job and all
these guys put you on the show let's
talk about [ __ ] and if they don't want
to get deep with you you know it's so
funny cuz when I went to let's go back
to what happened let's go back to what
happened to me in August
if that's the direction that you want to
go to all I want to know is I want you
could always talk to me I had to talk to
you and that's why and when you look god
listen when your dad passed which I know
that's where it's starting yeah I know
your world crumbled and it's been
crumbling and like you know but I I told
you I was there for you I knew you were
going to get help I don't how many times
I had to tell you I'm here and when I
say I'm here you know if I you're
deflecting you look at my Rudy poster
it's a real story though Sean asked
really good move very moving but go
ahead so we know I guess you lost your
dad yeah I lost my dad and um what
happened was my mom called me and she
goes on I was at I was at a hotdog place
I love hotdogs
I love Chicago and hotdogs because of
the peppers and that they add extra like
were you about to order the hotdog when
you heard this message or Joe I had the
hotdog on my hand okay and I didn't even
eat it I go what and I just didn't eat
it and then I went into panic next yeah
it was not even a panic it was more of a
um yeah it was a shock numb yeah it's
like when I was molested when I was a
kid by guy with Down syndrome it's true
story is your story he used to give you
candy yeah my point is is that it's the
same feeling of just like you do it's
almost dreamy and otherworldly it's not
good it's not a good feeling but it's
like what the [ __ ] this is like you know
you you know and so I called my brother
Steve my brother's freaking out and we
just booked the flight and then but you
know I had
a meetings in four years at 17 years of
sobriety and then next thing I know I'm
at a place called um I might have I
might have [ __ ] that weed dispensary
I want to say the name huh and I'm in
line to get weed after 17 years of being
sober I don't know how I got there bro I
was going home and I just pulled it was
called urban freeze grape establishment
great weed that's where you got your
weed that's right yeah and smoked weed
in 17 years so I ordered what I bought
was I bought hey do you have gummies so
I bought like 15 packets of gummies and
this is how alcoholic my brain is I and
I need because I didn't want to tell my
brother or my girlfriend or my mom that
I relapsed so I went to CVS and I got
melatonin melatonin gummy you know candy
know you can get melatonin ones at the
sleep sleep they're shaped like they're
gummy bears so you put them all in there
but I took all the I dumped that and I
put all the weed ones in there sure and
so when I was packing to go um that's
what I had and were they really like do
they ever this is the most strongest one
I don't know ten milligrams Pisa but oh
so evident after not getting high for
over 17 years you know I took one and I
just completely got almost way too high
were you upset with yourself no because
I was more upset about my dad I was just
like and also um I had this feeling of
like a new chapter like if you were
flipping a book that would that day was
the next chapter and it was gonna be a
long dark you didn't eat the hot dog you
took the melatonin the the gummies right
and you're on your way to your dad's
funeral no he's a hospital right so um
I'm completely hi we get to Arizona we
get to the hospice and my dad is um he's
lucid like he you know I walked in and
and he smiled I saw you why you smiling
because you just said he smiled so it
made me smile oh yeah I was in the
[ __ ] no no there so I'll he smiled
okay
and my brother and I look at each other
oh he's fine fine so then you know we're
like we kiss um and he's he can't talk
he hasn't been able to talk very long
time and even when he could talk you
couldn't understand him because of that
thick accent but um he basically said oh
you know that kind of thing and um
actually there was a sense of like why -
[ __ ] did I relapse he's not dying
what were he doing here but then the
lady came in it was telling all the
problems and basically she says so from
now on he can't either drink water or
eat we're not gonna feed him and then my
brother was like freaked the [ __ ] out my
brother was like wait wait wait what the
[ __ ] my burrito brothers TVs I destroy
oh what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
you gotta feed him like in a couple days
right no eat from now on yeah he's gonna
[ __ ] dive in right and they're like
yeah right because it's like if he had
it because he had all his lungs and
every the stomach had so much in just
what happened to my grandfather November
same thing yes I don't give ya do I
nothing so then you know now we have to
sit there for seven days oh and
sometimes it takes weeks yeah and to see
your dad
so from everyday he's now like you know
just dwindling and are you getting
higher and higher as you go in there
every day now you're getting used to it
yes Steve doesn't know about no one
knows about joy don't they look at you
and go are you okay you want something
no because you can brush it off as tears
and sadness tired fatigued yeah yeah oh
no I'm just tired and sad yeah I mean
gosh yeah cuz your eyes are all
bloodshot you can just you can you know
and and then my brother would stay there
at nights
my brother would stage sleep with him
yeah he would disturbing photos you take
photos like what dad's doing now and he
just like staring up at the ceiling you
know I mean like why do you want to see
that I know
exactly I mean I couldn't do that yeah
in fact when I saw my grandfather last
when I saw him in the home and I
remember he was sleeping with you know
he was uh sitting on the couch and all
these other old people around him
and I walked in there and you know my
grandma's like he's probably not gonna
remember Mike [ __ ] that he always
remembers me yeah won't but he said
Alzheimer's he goes I go I woke up
everybody in the place he his head lifts
up he goes Mikey oh it was a one in a
million and it was the last time I that
day was the last time I was with him or
like two more days and then I left and
then it all went downhill out of the
blue and he went to a hospice and they
were like you wanna come down I go no I
don't want to see him like this because
I knew what was happening
and I knew that I I wanted to remember
him this was for me it didn't bother me
uh he was like a father me I'd love I
love this man and I I didn't want to
watch him deteriorate
everyone's different and my uncle said
as long as you're okay with that I go
Irv would [ __ ] look at me and go what
do you do what is this why are you here
why are you don't get me go home I know
he wouldn't want me to see him like that
I just know we had a bond that's my
opinion of what I went through but that
everything's different so go ahead it
was it's a chance to witness truth us
Westerners have such a difficult time
with death you know I mean in Indian
stuff you know it's like it's the most
honest truthful thing that you can it's
a beautiful thing you know and I had to
witness it I was there when my dad took
his last breath you were there at that
moment yes did you say anything to him
at that moment he was he was in a coma
well I mean I couldn't say anything cuz
my mom and my brother were freaking the
[ __ ] out they were crying yeah yeah yeah
so when he takes his last breath they're
freaking out Bobby on gummi bears or
whatever you're kind of not okay but
you're with the mellow one oh yeah I'm
completely
namasté about it were you were keeping
them together I'm the oldest so maybe
that no that wasn't in in retrospect you
know at the time I could tell you that I
was being neo from the matrix and being
[ __ ] cool as em and yeah cute cool as
a cucumber but in retrospect I'll tell
you what later but what it was but when
he died I didn't feel anything and I had
sunglasses on
and Gucci and so and uh and my uncle
came in my since it's so funny my Mike
uncle my dad's brother youngest brother
drove from San Diego walked into the
hospice saw my dad's body got back in
the car and drove back eight hours how
long was he there for like one minute
what the footage did you say anything my
uncle what was it were they boys yeah it
was his best friend he just didn't want
to deal with it no it was really kind of
cool it was just like he looked at the
body and he made some sort of noise that
isn't my dad it was no word like a
prayer so it sounded Korean he looked
down on his got back in the car and we
go by he's drove off did you hug and
kiss your mom or you like no we took
photos stop he took photos of what my
mom wanted I didn't take photos of your
dad dead
yeah my mom goes we had to take photo so
I had to do like the timer thing with
the [ __ ] phone you had to set up a
time and reverse the image on your
camera
yeah and take a picture okay we got it
wrong he got it wrong you said it three
times
could you imagine some nurse just
standing there watching this I know it
was but why it seems odd to me maybe not
to you because I I wouldn't want to in
fact at the funeral I don't want any
pictures I don't wanna remember this day
I don't want to remember all the sadness
yeah my mom wanted it were you surprised
when she goes let's get a picture I was
like if that's what she wants so I did
the timer thing and we says we did this
you know I mean my dad was laying there
but you didn't do anything funny like
space right no we didn't do like the
Charlie's Angels but do you smile on the
photos no it's it I mean I could show it
to you but it wasn't yeah
well you're so funny because I sent it
to Kate and Oliver Hudson already in he
goes that's [ __ ] up don't ever do that
again
right you know Oliver yeah he was
charged you could see he thought he was
alive in the photo he said that's cause
you're dead sleeping I could know he's
dead and he goes don't you know and I
think you know he called me and I heard
Kate laughing in the background hello
Kate had some big fan but then what
happened was I got back into town all
right and then weird [ __ ] started
happening
like what well first of all I'm hiding
it from kalila my girlfriend that I live
with who I do a podcast with was it like
my best friend you're hiding what your
your emotion my you my using and you're
using yes now no I'm only smoking
I'm only smoking and vaping marijuana
right but you know when you're when
you've been sober for that long and
she's only known me sober and then when
I'm constantly 24/7 hi
it's weird she knows she doesn't know at
the time she just thinks I'm having a
[ __ ] meltdown because imagine like
we're in bed and like you know three or
four days in and when I get back
and she's like asking me a question and
I'm like giggling at a [ __ ] YouTube
video so she thinks she's having a
bright break yeah like I was nervous
right when I came on your podcast right
before you went to that well in the
center you were you were using yeah
you're like I'm high right now I
remember I think you said that yeah but
then what happened was not only am i
high but for some reason I can't get any
food in the food down so every time I
would eat something I would vomit in it
why well I didn't know why at the time
but I'll tell you why later but and then
not only that but I couldn't sleep so I
would get like 1 hours of sleep I
couldn't eat you know I was just
constantly high and then on top of it
hiding it from everybody and then on top
of it I got a job you know a network job
on a game show right right so it was
this game show where I had to do
aesthetic competitions I was up with a
UFC girl right I know with Rob
Gronkowski and Venus Williams and I'm
doing eight one-hour strenuous athletic
were you high during it not only high
not eating or sleeping did you have any
like did you ever fall down and like I
know my knee blew up to here because I
I ripped a 10-watt tendon right right I
couldn't walk sleep he I was dying and
like legitimate like I would be on sat
in front of like a live audience and
Keegan Keegan Keyes is hosting and
people would walk up to me go you know
what you're right and I'm just like you
know in my head I'm like I think I'm
gonna kill myself that's how you felt oh
yeah yeah you were embarrassed I don't
know I just didn't know what the [ __ ]
was going off completely heading out of
control out of control didn't know what
the [ __ ] was going on and it's so funny
because this happened in September so
it's not that far away and you're you're
grieving at the same time but you're not
grieving - yeah and I haven't really
cried over it either right so I'm now
having the suicidal thoughts and I'm
losing my mind and I mom I don't know if
the [ __ ] what's going on and then I
remember going on the road I go to
Portland and I remember taking my two
openers who are in a a because I had
booked them before I had relapsed so I
have two openers that are in a
Alcoholics Anonymous that are my friends
who not have to hide my drug use from
them
he's as well and then I remember taking
them to a sushi restaurant after one of
the shows and I took one bite of a
yellowtail sushi and it vomited all over
my [ __ ] shirt right in front of them
he's too [ __ ] narcs called kalila and
just telling me all this that stuff that
I'm doing right - collide and that
kalila
my girlfriend's going crazy did you fire
them no you see narcs you [ __ ] narcs
you were angry but now you're not angry
glad that at the time I was somebody had
to say something or you were going down
a slippery slope here right and then um
were you able to perform I don't even
remember but you were doing your act you
knew it so well that you were able to
play out I remember I remember I don't
know what that show was like I don't
know what the [ __ ] was going on did you
care no you really didn't care I didn't
care I think at one show I did like ten
minutes let's let's do 45 minutes I
think I did ten minutes they tell you
get back on stage do what's going on are
you having anxiety when you think you
could always use my dad died right
that's always a good one yeah it's a
good one yeah and so it won't work
face eagle he doesn't he's handsome
though we needed just a nice buzz killer
inside of you is brought to you by
Express VPN let me ask you Ryan which of
my online searches does the government
have a right to know about is it slurp
my Infocom mmm inside of you every
second of the month org not sexual
slimy booger central.com sanitary the
answer none of the above if you have
expressvpn without express VPNs
protection though hackers governments
and ad companies ISPs all have full
access to your data so I don't want them
using my web history or video searches
against me that's why I use expressvpn
every time I go online I always hear
about this you know if you go on
Facebook they get this and you can get
this if they they own your information I
always hear that it's a gosh man it's
everybody who's watching me all the time
expressvpn encrypts and reroutes your
web traffic to any number of countries
keeping you safer and secure simply
download the expressvpn app click to
connect and boom you're protected will
expressvpn you can make it seem like
you're browsing from a different country
so you can watch any netflix library in
the world that you want how cool isn't
it pretty cool expressvpn is the fastest
VPN I tried cost less than seven bucks a
month and comes with a 30 day money
guarantee it's time to stop governments
and Internet companies from keeping tabs
on your data
take back your online privacy like
Michael did expressvpn protect your
online activity today and find out how
you can get three months for free at
expressvpn dot-com / I owe you that's
expr ESS VPN com / I owe you for three
months free with a one-year package
visit expressvpn dot-com / I owe you to
learn more ok so this all comes down
kalila knows what's going on you get
back home she does music no she didn't
know I'm using she just thinks that I'm
having like that's something going on
and then what happened was um one day
she just says I think I'm gonna leave I
can't be in this I don't know what's
going on what yeah and I told her I
relapse
and then it was just chaos did she cry
or I'm pissed it was like chaos what the
[ __ ] you know meaning you just had moved
into your new house right yes I'm in
this new house it's it's crazy no
furniture it was crazy and then I go um
I don't know what's going on with me but
I have to finish this game Shou right so
I can and I will go to someplace I don't
know where I want to go Oliver wanted me
to go to the Hoffman Institute so I was
doing research on that but I don't know
but I I knew needed to do something
people I could legitimately feel myself
dying yeah you know I mean I know just
the physical and the mania you know in
the manic episodes and the eating and
sleeping so you imagine now a month and
a half two months in I'm still doing
this game show she's allowing me to use
I go I'm gonna use every [ __ ] day but
now I have to use regular marijuana
because the gummies is too much and if
you stop now it's like Jack Nicholson
doing coke and we'll just stop his heart
maybe I don't know it would probably
upset you cuz you're now your drug
addict yeah but now I'm stroking out 24
hours a day Jesus like I would do 300
400 hits are you able to be I know I
don't know why my mind went there are
you able to perform do you have sex with
us during the song on my dick is broken
like you're not even thinking of sex
you're not even involved in sex right no
she stays with you she's like yeah she's
barely hanging on but if you didn't tell
her at that moment be honest with her
she was gone yeah but also I was more
concerned that we were more concerned
about like me I lost 25 pounds in a
month and a half because I couldn't eat
and it could barely walk because I have
no energy and and so we're more
concerned about like my livelihood and
being alive isn't the right word likely
I don't know and so one day I am run
into a friend of ours and she's like you
look like [ __ ] and then she's like and I
she's like you got to see a therapist
see my therapist and I didn't know what
to do and I know why I said yes but our
I'll see your [ __ ] therapist but she
was
trauma therapists my name is Beverly and
I went and saw her and the miracle
happened it was a miracle so we're
talking what's going on I told her I
relapsed 17 years in that my dad died I
can't eat sleep my all that stuff and
then she's like didn't we go into like
what was like growing up and then that's
when I started talking about the abuse
sexual abuse no the physical abuse from
your father yeah you know my dad um I
just remember one time my brother and I
were sleeping I was maybe six years old
my brother was three and it was like
3:00 in the morning my mom runs in that
into her room and I remember her turning
the lights on and she opened her mouth
and all her teeth were gone cuz he
punched them out and then I remember him
trying to get into the room and I
remember my brother and I imagine
six-year-old three-year-old my mom
barricading the door you know because
what we know that once he gets in the
room we're all gonna get hit right he
would do [ __ ] like um just if you looked
at him wrong he would hit you as hard as
he could with a golf club
on your body was he drunk was just a
rage just rage is this something that
you always remember I always knew about
it did this bring it out did you get
this bring it out like all of a sudden
like wow this is what's up how you gonna
start from here what do you mean when
you go into therapy that stuff is that
what they're talking about going back to
the beginning well no we we were just
talking about like my dad and I was
saying I'm concerned that I didn't cry I
think that's what it started to go I
wondered she knew we explored that
aspect of you remember was your
relationship I go my relationship with
him was fine for the last since I became
a successful comedian you know that you
know that's when it you know kind of but
before that you know
it was just a Don work I'd say you're
saying that your relationship with your
father got better when he saw you being
successful so you felt like he started
to love you more yeah you know what
now it's tragic and I what whatever no
no I'm just while just telling you no no
I really appreciate that I'm hearing you
and then here's another story I remember
one time I had meningitis I was gonna
die and I remember we lived in Minnesota
and I remember like my dad wanted to
take the stairs to take me to the
hospital but my mom took the elevator
because we're like we live like seven
floors up in this apartment building and
I remember them pulling me and then my
dad let go of me and then he went tap
and he hit my mom in the mouth and I
fell to the ground but I usually
remember that [ __ ] that's why it's I
can't get that out of your [ __ ] head
to get out of your head so it's like you
know um and that was just continuous
right so that you always feared your
father
not just him he would beat the [ __ ] out
of but my cousin he was a crazy person
so everybody feared this guy yeah you
look now guess the big disconnect for me
is in a way I understand is that but you
still loved him and you still wanted his
approve you still water all these things
like that and even till the end it's
hard like sometimes you think I I know
he's your dad but sometimes you ever
think like it's still wrong and I it's
it's devastating what he did he he
affected me in ways that I could explain
to you later
of little things that I would do in
secret right to punish myself but Lee
Cho check it out but once I was in her
therapy office and I told her all these
things and I would remember leaving it
driving by a pen to express and I
ordered three different meals there
three different combinations I ate I
could eat again by just getting it off
your chest and then that night I slept
for the first time in months have you
ever tried EMDR that's what we did
that's what I did and it will make that
work dude I've never been that
hysterical in my life where you keep
doing the same thing a lot of events you
Oliver stay there stay there close your
eyes follow my finger follow my finger
yeah buddy I did the Machine I didn't
think I was worthy enough I was like
for pts this is for like veterans people
who lose let I didn't think my [ __ ] was
and all of a sudden she taps into
something yeah and this devastation I
felt as a kid comes out and what's crazy
about this is there's some science to it
but then you know that happen but it
doesn't affect you the same way that and
it worked for me it worked for you so
you were able to acknowledge that it
happened it's there you somehow forgave
him well what happened was after going
after leaving there and eating when I
was eating I thought to myself what
there's there's a connection now between
my my childhood and my trauma and my
body right I could could make that you
know the between the brain and your body
there's a connection between and I
thought to myself oh my god did I I have
to deal with this right so then that's
when I went to pcs and um Arizona how
long for two weeks and it was um from
7:00 a.m. to 9:00 p.m. you're in your
doing EMDR should do our therapies like
everything expensive yeah pretty
expensive
Gucci so you did you go in there think
were you up in mind her at first you
were kind of like and then all of a
sudden you realized wait a minute
something's happening well when I walked
in there the first day I remember the
lady Marilyn Murphy Kent comes out she's
explaining I'm in a group and you're
with the same group of the whole time
right and you're in a group with these
people that are like you know there's
one Orthodox Jewish guy with the little
hairs and the Hat Pierce's whatever and
then um you know mean there's a house ma
your how wife yeah
you mean you know there had someone
staying with me and like you have to
check out yeah yeah yeah so in the
beginning you're like a lot the [ __ ] is
exactly right [ __ ] but then it's so
funny cuz when it was over I didn't want
to leave them and they're my best
friends yeah you know you know it is you
feel safe for the first time in your
life I bet you really felt safe yeah and
I was so like working on myself I enjoy
the process of
better and dealing with things you know
so you know by doing that process I
remember I did an EMD our session and
what they made me do is they made me go
to a mall and go to a build-a-bear and I
go why do I have to go to [ __ ] a mall
and they go well because we want you to
UM make a doll that represents your
original child the child that first
comes out of the womb you know that
needs just love and sexual attention
nurturing all the things that a baby
needs you know and so I remember getting
the doll and I remember um when I was
eating with kalila Kalama went with me
to the mall it was holding the baby was
eating and she cried the way I was
holding the [ __ ] doll you're holding
yourself I was holding myself yeah and
you meant it you were doing the work
yeah you weren't trying to be funny you
were doing that yeah and then I didn't
that day later that day I did an EMD F
session where it was about one traumatic
experience with my dad and then she told
me to pull out my doll and then you know
tell your original self right
you mean to how you're gonna protect him
and I I ended up on the [ __ ] ground
crying so hard holding this thing yeah
and then um because I didn't greet my
dad and then when I walked out of that
session I said one thing and
like bro for two hour
to have people pick me up from the
South's fault I was crying so hard just
from that moment yeah like it all hit
you with one word just to aah yeah I
grieved right then and there and then
also when I went in there I got sober I
have uh 84 days now and so um you know
so I got sober there as well I go to a
lot of meetings every day every day yeah
when I was enough why you know when I
was shooting magnum p.i I went to
meetings on my off day which I'd never
used to do so I'm very um diligent and
um and I have a trauma therapy every
week with my counselor Beverly what is
that entail equity just a therapist
she's a trauma that I do am deal with
her does embr so I I did it too only
twice two days yeah and the first time
it really worked in the second time I
felt like it was forced like I'm trying
to force something out of me and I
couldn't get comfortable I couldn't do
it that's a part of it so you go you
know you have to be honest with yourself
and you know I'm a performer so we want
to like the performers right right so I
in the whole idea of 'i'm Dara's every
time it doesn't there's nothing you're
not gonna have a breakthrough sometimes
you're gonna be like I'm thinking too
much you know that stuff so you know you
have to do a lot you know and I have so
many you know I go to different memories
and you do EMDR sometimes a bunch of
sessions on one memory but what that
memory happens it just it becomes
smaller and the weight isn't as heavy
it's still there right yeah but um it
doesn't you know trauma not only does it
affect you mentally it affects you
physically I don't know
it causes I have tics and thing you have
caused from from things in the past and
I'm just like you know I get feeling my
body is you just haven't been let out
they're just like these dark yeah I feel
that same way you're more prone to
getting
cancers and strokes and whatnot and badi
badi age do you feel good do you feel
like you have you still have a lot of
work to do it you feel like I think I'm
now I'm feeling the way I should I
should have felt a long time ago well I
don't do the things here's what I wanted
to say to you is that you don't know is
is that every time I would before this
every time I would have a bad audition I
would have to bleed you'd cut yourself
No
would take a bottle of water and I'd hit
my head over the head a hundred times
until blood was over my face heydo every
time every time you you had a bad
audition or I perceived to had about
audition you know every time I make a
mistake I have to punish myself the way
my dad punishes me oh my god yes I never
knew anything yes so you know for a long
time you've been doing that all for 25
years it insidiously his his the effect
of my childhood has seeped into every
aspect of my life and so all those
things that I used to do to punish
myself I don't do anymore obviously and
number two because not only am ia aware
of the actions of doing it why I'm doing
it but it's also I don't feel the need
as much to do it I don't want to do it
you know and I think that has a lot to
do with dealing with you know mean I'm
not done with a lot of it right but
during the process of it it's really
just to help me out in my daily life in
terms of like even depression and um you
know eat like the things that we're
saying before making a grad tool is all
you know doing the tools routine yeah
yet to do it yeah you do you uh journal
now did they show you like the journal
every day or yeah man I [ __ ] journal
I do too I never done it god man [ __ ]
dude by the way alone away by your
vulnerability I can't I just can't
believe like I don't want it it's not
what I want I want comfortable like just
you know talk to me look I went through
this and you know I'm not comparing but
it's like wow just when I was like oh my
[ __ ] was tough on my body blunted do you
feel like now you're no I just feel like
I you know when you yeah I just felt
like no one was ever sort of taking care
of me saying I'm proud of you you're
good enough all these things that and
you never got you are like sort of
getting through other things attention
funny this we're doing all this blah
blah until one day you either decide to
find out what the [ __ ] this is all about
and then you dig deep and then you go am
i worthy I am worthy and I got to find
out why I'm worthy and I'm not stupid
I found a lot I was thought you're
incredibly stupid you're uh you're
there's just all these things I you know
it just was so overwhelming and I didn't
really know where it stemmed from and
when that comes out and it still happens
sometimes I get nervous cuz I'm like oh
my god I'm not gonna I'm not gonna I
hope that I was at the Magic Castle and
the magicians like looking right now
who's gonna be my helper might not me
I'm stupid I'm gonna [ __ ] your trick up
yeah oh I can pick me why right and it's
all stems from being that like that kid
who wasn't like you know good enough do
you I [ __ ] can't believe you went
through that [ __ ] what's amazing is
that's sort of what happened to me as I
kind of forgave at the end yeah I didn't
think I would it came out of nowhere
yeah I was like why am i what but you do
somehow that's the only way isn't it
it's a miracle though too that like you
know people with our backgrounds you
know sometimes you know even the
counselor said and I don't even
understand it really but they're like
it's a miracle that you even was able to
carve out any sort of resemblance of a
life right and I'm like in then they go
that's you know has something to do with
your resilience and survival techniques
I I always had humor as a defense
mechanism and I had no skillsets except
to be funny
and but I used that one skillset to
create a career right so you know in
many ways I could have become a serial
killer or a guy that caused other people
trauma like you could have done that no
but I'm just saying that a lot of people
with my background to have bat-crazy the
directory of their lives go a different
direction you know but for me I don't
know what it is but I was always like
even when I was 23 I remember being at a
comedy club an open mic and I remember
just going you have this is it that's
why all these
people from San Diego hated me back then
as an amateur because I would just so
like [ __ ] you mean I have to do this
is I have to be great that's just great
this is it I have no other fallback
position
I have no college degree I have no other
dreams as your purpose or did this or
nothing so when you're when you have a
kid like that you know I climbed pretty
fast you know I mean I start at 23 by
the time I was 30 I did The Tonight Show
which is a big thing for a kid from San
Diego with my kind of background you
know and I just crawled my way up to
that thing you know so but um but now my
life isn't about that my life is a you
know you know you say in the beginning
of the podcast you're doing great this
and that but I'm doing great in terms of
my mental health I think and that's all
I really right now care about all this
other stuff it's a fine and great and
you know I'm blessed and and and happy
and grateful I get depressed they just
want to be healthy I just don't want to
[ __ ] kill myself bro you still feel
like that do you so that's why right cuz
you're doing all the work
yeah and you feel like you're worthy
yeah like when I mean you know when I
was in Hawaii last week and I was like
I'll put it by the way I have to talk to
you about
so I go to mag and so I'm shooting I
should just show magnum p.i and this was
the first test of my you know my mental
health I show up and the director was a
guy named Peter Weller I remember Peter
well he's a tough guy he's a Robocop
yeah yeah yeah so you know what he said
to me the first day at work he was
directing the show his opening line to
me was this don't [ __ ] this up was he
kidding around I don't know I don't know
it's probably kidding around didn't
sound like to me right I didn't laugh
no and he walked away and then after the
first take of the first day he goes um
like that you don't like this no I don't
like it because it reminds me of my dad
and when I'm in when I'm around the
presence and I told that to
Hernandez in pretty two weeks who are
the stars of the show I could that's my
dad
because they did my podcast that
Saturday said you know they also I'm
friends with them so they know my past
as well and so on the whole time that
whole week shooting with this guy was
like Firefly for me man she's yeah it
was did you ever know that she ever tell
him yeah but you know me yet for me what
I did was I would just start saying [ __ ]
back yeah dude you know yeah I don't
respond to stuff like that that energy
you're mean and then like but I remember
the first last day of shoot I was like I
had this one complicated line I hated it
I didn't understand the line you
probably still remember it I don't even
remember I can't even say it because I
don't even know how that's how old
ifficult the line was pretty embarrassed
I don't care at this point that's good I
wish waited here I just wanna get the
[ __ ] out of the right it's embarrassing
yeah it really is I get embarrassed but
what's worse was him shamed me
afterwards
this exhibit out loud you that this guy
can't even do online and for the host
crew and they're all kind of haha
people are kind of uncomfortably
laughing and I'm sitting there just
staring at the table just going
it has nothing to do with you this is
just him it's been a personal this is
just his issues and also because I can't
do this one line eventually I think they
got it I don't even remember but also
you normally what I would have done a
year ago is go to my hotel room and cut
myself with razor blades I couldn't do
that one line you didn't do that no I
just sat there and what I was so happy I
almost felt like crying cuz you I was
sitting there going oh [ __ ] I'm
embarrassed I feel like you know he's
shaming me you know but I could separate
the fact that you know I mean I'm a
human being you know I mean under this
under this circumstance I don't really
perform great you me when I'm under this
kind of pressure and I know that about
does right so you know I was able to put
all into a cut into context and a
certain certain perspective and go it is
what it is it's a bad day is a bad week
I may never do the show again you know
and um it's okay you know Ryan all I
could think about is you're gonna have
to take the sound out of me biting my
nails I've never done this you have
caused me to bite my [ __ ] nail Hawaii
because I'm on edge with your story like
I've never been like this with anyone's
story like this is for me the most raw
honest thing and I know I you're my boy
and I appreciate you do it you're my boy
you're my boy but by the way you know
how he just wrote males gotta partner
yeah do you know what I do the opposite
thing and I'm and I'm I've got a you're
more mature right now doing what you do
because when there's a somebody on set
or somebody that's kind of being the guy
like no no this is gonna I always got it
my thing is like I'm not gonna [ __ ]
let that guy do that and it's like it's
like I don't like Authority I don't like
when people I could feel myself getting
worked up right now I remember this guy
Michael Ironside and his scanners number
his head me I don't know what the [ __ ]
was going on but I was on the Smallville
set and you know I've been on the set
for years and I'm like laughing and
talking everybody and I'm not gonna blow
up and this guy goes that's me who's
this guy huh
he's directing no he's looking he's just
an actor on the show guest star
this guy yeah what's going on man what's
going on with you huh and I go are you
serious right now he's like yeah you're
that guy right yeah I was gonna be the
funny guy I gotta be this he's just
calling me out yeah and I feel it I feel
like I feel gonna be ashamed I feel like
that father figure I feel yeah yeah I'm
being a kid again being reprimanded and
it's gets it's brewing and I'm like oh
my god I was in such a good mood and now
I'm just like I don't know what's going
on I'm really right now yeah and I go
yeah hey man you could be this guy when
it's you know when you're one of the
leads on the show not when you're a
[ __ ] guest star I just looked at him
right in the [ __ ] eyes I just was
like you're not gonna [ __ ] come in
here and like make me feel like this
[ __ ] in belittle me in front people so I
don't like it sometimes when people when
people push my buttons I don't do it
often but when someone gets under my
skin yeah and really comes after me yeah
or just and I give him a chance like
okay haha okay huh
and then when I hit that point it's like
[ __ ] you man now we're on and it was
just one of those moments where like
dude I don't [ __ ] care I remember
there's been moments in my life like
what am i doing I remember I mean give
me the story give me the story I love my
buddy in Vancouver once we're just going
across to my other friends Tom the knee
and you know I was doing a show up there
and he was doing something else and I
was bald and I remember him kind of
smacked me in the bald head it was cold
as winter yeah dude cut it out man yeah
like pop and I go dude it hurts man stop
that so yeah they did it again
yeah and finally I go hey stop doing
that man and then a few minutes later
pop and I turn to him much bigger
brawler to kick my ass in a heartbeat
and I go buddy if you [ __ ] hit me one
more time I'm gonna punch you in your
[ __ ] face I don't care if you beat me
up
I will get one [ __ ] punch and I will
[ __ ] bust your face up do it one more
[ __ ] time and I remember he just goes
dude calm down
you didn't [ __ ] hit me because he knew
that I was gonna [ __ ] do something
yeah
at least I'm not the guy where you say
one thing I'm gonna push my button yes
dad I remember yeah I remember one
director once there's another one a
Smallville he's like look hey you know I
got to get the flight out cuz I gotta
get home to whatever I have a family
thing yes yeah yeah I know he's being
cocky about it and then I remember he
goes and well he knows a story it was
Clark Kent on Smallville he goes finally
I go dude we got to get to this scene he
goes you know what we're not gonna do
that scene today you're not gonna make
your flight we're gonna shoot it
tomorrow morning you know why because
I'm the director and I remember looking
at him and going
guys for the crew I go you know I'm a
humble person I would never do this or
say something like this unless I was
provoked by a fat ass director I go I'm
one of the leads on the show you know
who's getting fired first you [ __ ]
and then the ad comes out to me baby
comes up we talked about this offset I
go we certainly can and this is a big
dude I know again I get my asking but
he's like [ __ ] with me why are you
being a dick I'm not being a dick yeah
and then he goes he and I all I did was
this I'll never forget I go look man
like that he goes like he thought I was
gonna hit huh I go what you want to
[ __ ] fight me you want to fight me
now it was so uncomfortable
I loved it was so but it's just like you
know I I guess it's like people push
your buttons man yeah I've lost my [ __ ]
are you thinking of cutting that no well
he was looking at me oh that's the good
[ __ ]
you can't cut that so look I feel like
you and I feel like this insecure kid
and then something comes out of me like
I can't I can't I can't be I'm gonna
shut down I'm gonna fight him you fight
you fight you fight I fly you know I
mean I'm the flight I aura fries
I either fries or a flight you're a
fighter but it's the same I don't know
if I'm always a fighter I think I freeze
to know I've never fought back but you
know what I want to fight I think you
would I'd rather I think if somebody
treated you like that I'm sitting now
with your improvement and all the [ __ ]
you're working on you you know what
buddy don't talk to me like that
just don't talk to me yeah mind your own
business yeah and that will make you
feel good I remember I had a director
who call me a racial slur what do you
say Sims are like eight ching-chong you
mean can't you see through those
ching-chong eyes or something like yeah
and I remember going does I'm sorry
like I coward and it's one of those
things were in my mind I'm like I wish
cuz I was a young guy he was in like the
90s
you should have power or something yeah
a feat that now oh he would never work
again no I would call everybody it would
be a disaster yeah I would almost Tiger
belly people how are you it would be
disaster for him yeah but I love [ __ ]
like that hey listen this is I have a
patreon account and these are people who
subscribe to the to my patreon bootiful
you
and I know you have one but they really
help support the show they do because I
thought I need them I'm not like you
know okay this is called shit-talking
questions these are from patrons or some
good questions here quickly answer me
don't have to take a long time
I want to Raj Raj what's your go-to
karaoke song um tequila tequila yeah cuz
you don't sing much wait is there much
new words just one word that's it yeah
did you just come up with that no you're
releasing that yeah
tequila if they ask because I don't like
doing karaoke I'll go I'll do tequila
Angie what would you say is the most
unhelpful advice you've given on your
podcast to date that when you said
something you went back and go what the
[ __ ] was I giving that advice for uh uh
yeah usually cut usually um if somebody
doesn't want to have sex with somebody
because it's a and just I say leave them
alright well so I remember somebody
saying like you know I'm dating this
girl it's three months in she might have
sex with them and I go just leave the
[ __ ] you know I mean kind of thing
Wendy could have been seventeen who
knows a scenario yeah well you didn't
know yeah Sophie em any funny stories
from the kickin it old-school movie
that's what we do I remember you and I
were naked a lot well you showed me your
penis you show me yours first you did I
don't know if that was true I went under
percent because I remember the day was
that when we bonded no I walked into my
own trailer and I turned around and you
were leaning against a wall in my own
trailer with the penis out would that be
considered harassment to her not to me
that's a Korean hello Tom funniest story
about filming MADtv
oh my god I have so many what's the one
that just [ __ ] comes to light
well there's one that I haven't really
told much which is just one day that a
Jordan Peele
Jordan Peele was like um one day he did
he only had like one scene where he had
to carry in a glass of water he was a
waiter right so he had just rights but
then he got really high he you know he
had no line right but we knew that he
wasn't gonna be able to do it because he
was so high because he had to balance
his glass it hidden he just had to put
the [ __ ] glass on the table right I
don't know we're all sitting behind the
monitor watching Jordan come out and
just seeing the [ __ ] hearing and it's
Felix chattering hey he didn't know you
were [ __ ] with him no it was so fun
but that was the lab memory
Andrew see what's the worst celebrity
interaction you've experienced Omar
Weller no
that but I have another one that was uh
Tom Selleck no last summer and then even
[ __ ] know the guy and he kind of
yelled at me for no reason it was like I
was doing Pauly Shores movie which is uh
you know what's called it was funny the
documentary thing no it was a real movie
mother scripted movie right and Billy
Zane was on it and I had just gotten a
set and somebody was like hey look at
the set I walked in i was just talking
and the Beleza hey shut up to me right
and I just got I don't know if the [ __ ]
is going no one told me that they're
shooting anything and I remember looking
at Billy Zane going oh you want to go
there I'm small you're a handsome guy
you're a Titanic I got nothing we'll see
what goes on now you want to have a war
with me because you don't even know what
I have have an army Billy are your
friends now I don't think I'm getting
married be good question would you could
you play a serious role in a non comedy
series yeah I would love to I know you
can I would I've done it
Lisa any upcoming acting gigs thought
you were great in splitting up together
in love but uh and love both were
brilliant a shows that ended too soon I
saw you on the S I wrote a show with my
friend and it's about a Korean spa in
Koreatown and it's a three camera sitcom
about a Korean family that runs this
really bad Korean spa and see CBS
Studios about it are you serious yeah
but we got to write it and do the pilot
well that's the it's gonna work you
gonna get good writers don't deflect
with the tongue slap Nikko P Nikko how
do you know when you're in the zone when
you're on stage during I said how do you
know when I [ __ ] God oh here's the
thing there's two things that you have
to remember when you're about to perform
there's two feelings that you have
number one each sometimes you have to
push your way up on stage but then
sometimes you get pulled do you see me
other different pushing is like get the
[ __ ] on cuz you don't feel like yeah
funny you got it it's like something's
pulling you like I can't wait to get up
how often do you get pulled rarely but
when I get pulled it's always great a
lot of trick yeah I have to take a [ __ ]
in your bathroom can i I think that
a perfect way to end this podcast buddy
this is this has been amazing you got
Tiger belly and the other show is bad
friends bad friends with Andrew Santino
Andrew said he's gonna come in the park
I should get him on here right no he
said he was gonna do it listen thank you
yeah I know and I know you'll do it here
listen thank you for allowing to be
inside you I love you this was a joyous
I want to come back and Tiger belly as
you know when you need a guest last
minute you know to call me right yeah
Bobby Lee thank you thank you guys oh
yeah did I love that guy Bobby Lee's
he's you know
yeah just a beautiful mess dad I think
that's the best way to put it yeah he's
got a big heart
I know his story I've known him forever
and it's just lovely to he's just always
so uh he's a good friend you know I've
talked about this before I think but you
know the people come back in the podcast
is it's really just uh everyone's busy
who wants to go it was someone's podcast
mother who wants to go again Stephen
Amell did Bobby Lee Tom Welling
jamie-lynn Sigler jennifer Love Hewitt's
coming back this is uh this is nice it's
nice when you have friends that will
come over and cuz they know I love this
they know I'm doing something good they
know that it's like I'm passionate about
it and I think they uh it's nice you
know I want to give a big shout out good
buggabugga a big shout out to all the
patreon the top-tier patrons without you
guys I don't know if we'd be able to run
the show and that's Allison L Andrew see
Angelina GE Lee Barry I Bobby Board Tex
we got Brian H what if I just started
making up words
we're like Brian tej me Brian hot as
hell Chris he doesn't have a last name
on here Deon K doesn't work
Emily Emily s Hamza B Hamza sounds like
a new name Hamza Jason D Jason W
Jennifer s we met on Facebook and you're
just so sweet you're a new top tier I
love you Jerry W you're new I love you
Jerry W Jill a Joshua D Kevin R Lauren G
Leah s you know I love you stubby mark a
Michael ask Nancy D my love me come I
love Wragge
Robert B rocks Rach
food is in the hizzle Samantha M CeraVe
Sean W Stacy L T Anna
Tricia Vanessa in the sky and you go
yeah a lot of new patrons and what a
treat man I don't know what I do without
you guys thank you all the new top-tier
patrons oh thanks to all my patrons like
I said whether it's a buck or Nothing or
whether you just listen for free or if
it's 25 bucks or whatever they did just
amazing just thanks man thanks for
everything thanks also please follow us
inside of you on Facebook Instagram
Twitter YouTube really helps get those
numbers up sponsors look at that [ __ ]
always you got this many spunk of
subscriptions or this it helps so it
might mean nothing to you and you listen
to it and I love that it's free for you
but for us it helps us out so make sure
you follow on Facebook Instagram Twitter
it's either at inside of you pod or at
inside of you podcast and again
subscribe to the YouTube channel get
start watching that get those numbers up
Ryan man be safe be healthy you know
here's that theme music I love the theme
music that we did it was so good right
oh it was just we winged it it was one
take whatever it is it is but maybe we
could write something to go in that
could be our own we can write something
more with words sad okay yeah so thank
you guys for listening to Bobby Lee and
yeah the merch stores inside of you
online inside of you online store
whatever they have tons of hats and
shirts and all that stuff and um anyway
thank you so much for listening we'll
we'll see you next week and thanks for
allowing to be inside of all of you
[Music]